the situation in odessa is there is now
as we've seen across ukraine the most
remarkable effort by
civilians to try to protect their
beloved city here on the southwest coast
of ukraine it is a critical target for
vladimir putin if he is able to capture
odessa he will be able to cut off
ukraine from the sea it is a critical
sea port and it is the beaches that are
now being fortified by civilians to
protect themselves from the might of the
russian army just have a look at this in
the summer by the way they're sunbathing
and fun on these beaches today they're
digging and digging filling sandbag
after sandbag to try to protect these
beaches it is the most remarkable effort
in the most terrible chilling weather
let's just have a look around here the
several beaches across the coast here on
the southwest coast of ukraine
350 000
sandbags have been filled by these
people in the last two weeks alone while
they're doing that well they fear that
out there in the black sea there is a
buildup of russian military and navy
that have plans to try and mount some
kind of amphibious assault on the
beaches of odessa and the odessans are
not going to have any of it they say and
so these sandbags are going to be put
out across the coast here to try to
prevent that from happening
the president of ukraine vladimir
zelinski said that he has information
that the russians plan to attack odessa
just within the next few days and if
he's right
then this
might might just be able to stave that
off but it's hard to see how that can be
possible just look at this effort a
human chain look at the weather it's
absolutely freezing cold and yet they're
still putting these sandbags on the back
of these lorries and moving them to
wherever they feel they can be uh be
beneficial
now we do know that vladimir putin has
his sights set on odessa it's the pearl
of the black sea it's a hugely strategic
port and there's all sorts of activity
going on up and down this coast but here
right now i have to say that it's quiet
and you could say eerily quiet but there
is some intelligence to suggest last
week that the some russian navy ships
were spotted off the coast it's a murky
dark a murky windy day today and you
can't see any evidence of that but what
you can see is a huge effort to try and
fortify the beaches here just behind me
in normal times just a few weeks ago
this was a yacht club in the summer
people come here they have fun they
enjoy the coastline and now look at it
you know it's just the most remarkable
effort being played out in front of us
in the town they're building barricades
almost on every street the cafes
odessa's famous for its really
picturesque cafes i was here about five
years ago sitting having tea in the
square now it's completely deserted
those big steel blockades the hedgehogs
designed to stop tanks rolling through
the city they're almost on every corner
and there is a bit of a twitchiness in
the air
but here on the coast
the sandbags are really the key
but i it just makes you wonder
just what and how effective they'll be
against the might of the russian
military who seemed
really dead set on taking odessa
it really was the sort of jewel in the
crown of the soviet union and vladimir
putin has big ideas about new russia and
it would be hard to see odessa not being
a big part of that
and so they're doing all they can and
they're waiting uh for what might happen
in the next few days it's cold it's
windy it's snowy
but it's not putting them off